foreign
do you know what the realm is
it's the Thousand Blades of aegon's
enemies a story we agreed to tell each
other over and
until we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones in
House of the Dragon update video alright
my friends in this new video I will be
discussing some very exciting
information regarding House of the
dragon's second season as I'm sure most
of you already know by now HBO will
begin filming its second season of House
of the Dragon this March that's only
about five weeks away so as you can
imagine we will begin learning a lot new
information about what's happening
behind the scenes as they make their new
season for the hit show now according to
this new article HBO is looking for
actors to film one of its biggest scenes
for the second season this information
is actually from a very reliable source
who also revealed a lot of exciting
details about House of the Dragon when
they were filming the first season so
let me show you what they had to say
alright so according to redanian
intelligence HBO might be looking for
new actors for House of the Dragons
blood and cheese scene the second season
of HBO's hit series House of the Dragon
starring Emma Darcy Matt Smith and
Olivia Cook have finally started
production at least in studios we are
yet to hear any big casting news such as
Craig and Stark Darren Targaryen or
Elise Rivers but we have started hearing
something about casting already it seems
HBO is looking for a set of young actors
we are hearing that house of the Dragon
is currently looking for blonde Twins
age three or four who have shoulder
length hair to film for a few days
sometime between April and June of this
year now before getting into the roles
we should discuss their schedule this is
the most recent schedule we have for
House of the dragon's second season at
the moment there were various reports
that filming would begin in March of
this year and that may still be accurate
but now we know that there will be
filming this April now for the record I
still fully believe filming will begin
in March because it was already
confirmed by several sources who work at
HBO now the only real mystery is are
they actually casting these young actors
for the blood and cheese scene well the
blonde actors who are aged three to four
will most obviously portray Targaryen
children there can be a little doubt
about about that however the question
Still Remains which Targaryen kids will
they be the biggest example of a scene
that would require Targaryen children is
the infamous and much anticipated blood
and cheese scene where we will see
Helena's children the Twins jaharis and
Jahira and their younger brother maylor
in George R Martin's novel Fire and
Blood Jahira San Jahira were six years
old when blood and cheese happened but
in House of the Dragon last we saw them
in the episode The Green Council they
were slightly younger thus the age
requirement of three to four seems to
fit in this instance now there can be
other options for this casting of course
but blood and cheese is naturally the
first option where the Mind goes when
hearing their requirements not that long
ago House of the Dragon writer Sarah
Hess was hinting at the blood and cheese
storyline in a variety interview saying
I don't think the fans will be
disappointed and I believe we will find
out very soon like I've said in other
videos as soon as filming does begin in
March we will start to see photos and
videos from the set in and that will
start to give us a very good idea of
what will be happening in the second
season we will begin to get a lot of
information and only a few weeks from
now so make sure you subscribe that way
you're always up to date with everything
happening in The Song of Ice and Fire
Universe I will be here making videos
about everything regarding Game of
Thrones House of the Dragon The Winds of
Winter the Jon Snow series Duncan egg
and so much more as always I want to
thank all of you for watching this video
let me know what all of you think Down
Below have a great day everyone I will
see you again very soon bye
two men were found one was a former gold
cloak the other a rat catcher in the red
keep who knew all its secrets
history remembers them only as blood and
cheese
one night Queen Helena entered the Royal
apartments with her daughter and two
sons to put them to bed without warning
blood and cheese bursting daggers in
hand they told her that a debt was owed
a son for a son blood and cheese
demanded she choose which son would be
ripped from her forever
Queen Elena pleaded with the man to kill
her instead but they refused
weeping Helena named her younger son
Milo
perhaps she thought the boy was too
young to understand
or perhaps because the older boy was
King aegon's first born son and Heir you
hear that little boy she's whispered to
the younger son your mama wants you dead
then blood struck off the older boy's
head with a single blow when the gods
burst in they found Queen Helena still
screaming clasping her dead son's body
to her mad with grief
the blood of their children transformed
a dynastic dispute into a war of
annihilation
the grief and rage of losing a child
could burn down the world
either aegon or anira could live at the
end but not both
[Music]
foreign